so rubidium is one of the elements that
was discovered by Bunsen the German
chemist who invented the Bunsen burner
and as far as I remember it was because
he was analyzing mineral water that came
from some German star and he discovered
the colors of the different elements in
the flame of his Bunsen burner he's an
interesting guy because apparently he
did so much glassblowing that his
fingers lost all their nerves at the end
and he could work til his fingers were
black and smoking but the chemistry
rubidium is not widely exploited but it
is used a lot by physicists for whom
rubidium vapor is one of the main things
they use for excitation by lasers there
are all sorts of effects where with the
right sort of lasers you can do very
interesting experiments you can shine in
a laser that is red and it will come out
as blue you can shine lasers onto
rubidium atoms and stop them moving and
there so it is the real workhorse of
laser chemists or laser physicists but
not really used very much by chemists